game well it depend on what race you
are what race is the best race to learn
how to shoot guns honestly to learn how
to
shoot hello hello it depends on uh what
you would want to shoot what about how
how you want to be accurate or do you
want to look cool criminals and Nells
and uh law Breakers what's the best gun
to shoot law Breakers with to shoot law
Breakers with probably like a the old
school rock
slingshots get the [__] off my
launch got a real AR yes guys
Texas this man Hans is
whiling he goes he walked in with that
and he says thanks for doing my podcast
with that in his I thought he was about
to say trick in word and it just
unloaded I was call written housing
it I just had it strapped walking around
it is it is fun though honestly that's
like a really sexy looking gun yeah you
can pretend to do anything with it that
you can normally do with a gun and you'd
want to fantasize about doing with a gun
yeah what do you fantasize about doing
rounding
Corners busting through doors yeah
saving lives by Taking Lives sometimes
it has to happen getting to have sex
with someone afterwards cuz you did such
a good job with a
gun that does turn a lot of people on
like if they see you with something and
it's like and you do good with it maybe
that's why like uh people are attracted
to like what girls like attracted to
like fishing or whatever like if they
watch you catch a fish like oh my God we
should [__] may you like they watch
someone kill someone you think they're
just just as horny
after yeah or
hornier hornier or horny and H women
women they get horny fish fish and guns
or when they see you selling drugs on
the street corner yeah it racial sorry
being racist just cuz you're
black um but yeah I mean that's just
like a way to survive in a different
environment that's like fishing yeah in
the hood I don't know yeah whatever the
top dog attractive thing would be have
you been you lived in the hood right no
I've never lived in the hood never I
don't know what you consider the hood
have I lived in a lowincome
neighborhood probably all right have you
ever had uh um first of all have you
ever lived in a place where like the the
houses weren't separated by a fence or
anything there was it was just house
house house house house you know you
just had you know no fences I mean I had
a fence in the backyard but not the
front yard okay all right that's close
that's close and low income and
neighbors who also were in low income no
they were in high
income then I don't know I don't have to
live in the hood to be a person that is
true but I do think every person should
experience the hood if that like you
know why it's it it'll teach you things
it's knowledgeable you know I'm saying
what about like people that live in
Sweden like so you think we should
always just go to the lowest pretty sure
there some hoods in
Sweden definitely yeah like every
there's a dude who on YouTube who just
we just have to experience the worst
thing possible to feel good about
ourselves all the time or do you think
we can like you know learn how to be a
person without having to go through the
worst thing possible all the time
honestly I think you have to go through
the worst
[__] so then what about people that go
through the worst [__] and then get
destroyed by it you want strong enough
get
stronger all right bet but that worse
that's worse that's worse than just
having someone weak that's around that
can make you like
cookies why why is cookies that what you
went
with
yo what's good
n it's live right what you're saying
Hans but I definitely think I I I think
it has to happen I think you you have to
for the for the car for the for the life
content for the development of the
character wouldn't it be if you could do
the same result but without any poverty
but you don't get the same result
they're lot like like a lot of them hate
it like 90% of the result without having
to go poverty like what is the limit
like what is the limit of suffering that
you're willing to have just be better at
basketball [__] you I'm already great
I'm better um you guys talking
basketball we uh well now we
are
I think poverty is great but it's like
kind of [__] if your whole system
relies on poverty to produce Talent now
that that's that's different that's not
that wasn't the question it wasn't
solely to produ what the hell is this
it's how Aubrey Hein used to smoke oh
[__] we like the the the uh fancy
British [__] the the princesses yeah
we a bunch of
fat I feel like this is some [__] they
would smoke out of in Princess
Diaries my first joint
very quirky yeah no I was saying to Hans
that uh I think everybody should
experience the hood in some way and
that's how that whole conversation start
I think everyone should experience the
hood you
know and he was saying why why do like
do we have to experience the worst
things to you know like do we have to go
through and experience worst [__] to
appreciate our lives or we could just or
you know we could just you know it would
be you people would live the same lives
yeah but that's initially what I said
saying because we were talking about
Switzerland or whatever and I was they
probably have a hood out there too you
know like they got they got hoods in a
bunch of [__] places yeah their hoods
is only a three-bedroom
house I think if you're trying to be a
good basketball player play basketball
don't go really hungry and starving and
have shootouts in your neighborhood you
don't think that helps a distraction
shoot out your you make you Mak you
that's the that's the scramble you got
to be elusive depends on if you're
trying to make a Detroit Piston or a
Steve Steven Curry cuz Stephen Curry had
nice parents right he Curry yeah uh
let's
see where I don't where did he grow up
wasn't his dad a pro basketball player
yes however well I mean all right all
right that's different that's different
that's different it still happens
obviously you get the like that you know
he his life was probably set up to do
this anyway it's kind of like Hollywood
like but there's still you got to use a
different example Hans that's not a
because you can't use the the most
privileged person like there's still
people in in the league who didn't have
NBA parents and came from nothing and
still made it to the league
now I
mean going straight to Steph Curry is is
cheating so why is it cheating because
he's like a perfect example of
yes you can't okay this is like a
conversation when you have like with
girl and you come up with a perfect
example it's like but not that one that
one even that would even count actually
I think it's a good way to make awesome
people I just don't think that we should
continue to do it too much okay cuz it's
like for every one LeBron James is
probably like a thousand Grandma
freezing in an
apartment you why you think that's
because the people don't make it to uh
the NBA and they just use all their
Grandma's resources yeah like just
believe yeah somewhere in there is a
grandma that could have been saved but
LeBron James just takes it all yeah well
H is saying is some of y'all are just
taking all your parents resources and
not going to pan out you know they could
be using that money and your career is
not going to that's what you're saying
right now people the people are chasing
their dreams at basketball yeah stop
chasing your dreams feed your
grandmas don't contribute to the economy
listen she lived her life before you got
there she had her fun it's is your turn
now yeah midsommer her off the [__]
top of a
ghetto you guys get me his pass do you
want to scoot in a little closer how
far's his arm going not that far don't
change that don't can you not do that
okay yeah just don't
touch this is the funniest thing ever I
mean I guess it doesn't go that
far I guess that's good because then
Bobby's oh [__]
yeah I they got it to the ashtray once
you want to hold the AR yes oh I already
held it you hold it I like how I sit
down I immediately have a gun pointed at
me within two seconds I'm like this
would be a fun podcast just AR pointed
at my [__] face you didn't
acknowledge it at all either I think
that's the craziest part I looked at the
barrel I not to grab it by the trigger
yes
damn nothing in it it's probably better
did not have it out during a podcast but
I couldn't resist yeah definitely gives
you
clout let's the redditors know what's up
before when they're about to hit that
keyboard [__] remember the AR dude
don't even
[__] where did you order this from hunt
there some guy is a kill Tony fan and he
made it for me this dude made you this
gun he bought all the parts and put it
together he didn't like make it s you an
Ikea go grinded off the serial numbers
himself
he 3D printed the parts smuggled them in
his [__] I think he's going to be
extremely happy that using it but I
wonder what he wanted you to use this
for
exactly I think you know
exactly H you're out there in Texas with
a lot of legal
Mexicans I'm going to send you this
whatever you do was on you
brother the oh my God
the Border what's your thoughts on the
border well I was just laughing earlier
because the few things that Republicans
don't like are trans people in the
border so they they don't like
transitions of any kind is what I was
laugh earlier yeah they uh they don't
like the in between they're like you're
either in or you're out if you're out
you stay out if you're in you stay in
you have a penis you have a penis and
stay in the country that you're from
don't change your genitor don't change
your country everyone stay where you are
and have the genital that you have yeah
stop changing don't change everything's
fine everyone needs to stop changing
that is what conservatism is right you
know great yeah they're conserving
tradition that sounds like that would
for sure be Trump's next speed like if
he had all the power if he had real
power be like all right I want the
election again everyone stop the only
thing you can do is age yeah stay in
your that's actually that would be a
[__] hilarious CH
speech you want water I'll take a little
water thank you you can put it you Dr it
out of the suar Shan thermos I was
wondering what that meant is that a com
is that a person is that a
merch see oh yes oh [__] you said is
that a comic podcast he's a he's a
friend of the show yeah he's a real nice
dude man yeah oh is he the one with the
wild hair who's okay yeah he's [__]
he's a real deal he's scary dude he's
funny and he's strong and beautiful and
do you love him creative yeah yeah you
could say I'm in love
no when uh when he was here uh for the
kill Tony thing uh the arena bro he had
so much jewelry on it was insane he was
he was actually on my episode of kill
Tony he was the guest it was him and Joe
list um what a weird combination of
guests yeah yeah the oppos
fighter speaker to the
fighters we must have you speak to the
jock it was the most random episode ever
but
gonna be our liazon yeah yeah J
literally doesn't have a chin as they
say in
F yeah he's uh going to get knocked out
pretty quick but maybe Fighters like
that cuz then it's like oh you're just a
not a threat I don't all my defenses are
useless against you I'm used to fending
off rear naked chokes I'm not used to
some guy that's going to be like oh
while you're choking me out you're kind
of a
[__] if you think about it yeah yeah he
just spins it back around with verbal
Jiu-Jitsu yeah actually this is that
you're
gay oh my God yeah the pen is mightier
than the
sword whoever said that probably never
got stabbed before I would say yeah you
know yeah that's before death death
squads in Central America and
assassinations and the
Mumba being
assassinated
the sword's pretty Mighty I've never
swung a real sword but it looks so cool
in every like show that I've ever
watched what if you could have a pen
sword you mean like a Percy Jackson one
where he he clicks it and it becomes a
real sword yeah that honestly I that
would be I would buy that but to I love
your cultural references I thought
that's what you brought up no I I'm in a
different world than you I guess I don't
know what if you could combine the pen
and the sword and that's how you get the
UFC and Dana White he has a Penny sword
is a swordy
pen I mean I don't think you're supposed
to turn into the pen or the sword I
think it's you're supposed to use it
yeah so he's got the pen in one hand The
Sword in the other the UFC guys are all
sword that's the good thing about UFC is
you get animals you're just like we're
going to breed animals that are
humans and you get the best stock or
whatever just have them [__] each other
Ronda Rousey [__] Travis Brad that
kid is going to be
crazy cross like pets Travis Brown is
like a [__] Hawaiian
yeah he's just tall
and really big what what is The Ultimate
Fighter if you could Pokemon bread them
together if you had your your brothers J
Jones with Daniel cormier's
body yeah that that is The Ultimate
Fighter two dudes two
that's what the gays are here for the
gays started coming around and then we
got the UFC coincidence oh any gay
people in U I don't watch it every
no not really there's there's got to be
no there's not not openly there's got to
be Buys in there for sure but they don't
talk about it yeah or else they'll beat
you up I think suppos to talk
of that's D's rule they never get far
enough because they don't mind losing a
little bit you know there's part of
them that's
so homophobic of you to think that
gayness is associated with
losing maybe it's not as testosterone
you guys want to win too
manag he's the number one Contender he
want I meant more specifically in the
sense of uh when it comes to getting
humped and dumped getting into uh
wrestling match with a
man side
control yeah oh no I lost lips I don't
think that they get turned on by that I
think that they're in fighting
mode punch in elbow to the face gay sex
mode that is true it is absolutely true
I'm gonna look it up man there's no the
UFC in the
UFC
yeah well we do have the rainbow merch
over here
huh is very odd that there's been such a
like I think we've lost sight on it just
because it's so normal because of Rogan
but it's like there's such a marriage
between fighting and comedy which is
like what a strange Two Worlds to have
like what do you mean intertwined
fighting and comedy well that like the
fact that you like know that like that
you like you would not think those two
worlds would connect at all and there's
like a huge overlap now because of Rogan
yeah this is like a alternate universe
it's like what if
Fighters watched comedy yeah cuz of
course comedians watching comedy were
like oh look real men wow but Fighters
being like yes the intellectual Arts we
must soften
ourselves for the comedians they are
fulfilling their role in society as I
am yeah we're we're artists that's
that's a word I'd use for comedy
probably art soft art
right you're right it says there are no
openly gay P I mean do they call them
players I don't know if they call them
players Fighters they call them
Fighters it would take away a lot of the
[__] talk because all the [__] talk is
pre-fight is just being as aggressively
homophobic as possible oh dude yeah when
I when uh I wasn't big into it but back
when McGregor and Mayweather were
fighting that's when I used to watch the
stuff that he would say butg Gregor was
like oh man this guy's got a book bag
you can't even read
dude that
[__] he was one of the best [__] talkers
I've ever seen in my life it was so
entertaining I would watch just a
compilation of that even over we
fighting probably oh just them talking
[__] to each other [__] talk I it has to
be the good ones though you know not not
everybody can cut a good
promo yeah a lot of them are kind of
bores a lot of them are kind of
extremely have head injuries yeah just
making nonsense they have like sure
they're making nonsense schol [__] I
know he
said have you seen uh Conor
McGregor talking [__] and uh Nate Diaz
is like my whole crew will wh whip your
whole
crew so you're playing touch but in the
park with that dork no I haven't seen
that one it's funny no they're on MSNBC
and natez is like what is this the money
Channel why am I on the money Channel
that's the dude him and his brother are
Fighters he's is that the skinnier one
or the bigger okay it's the younger one
I think that dude's badass apparently
everyone in Florida loves him I think
he's from somewhere like he's in from
Stockton California oh well I don't know
he was yeah he embodies the spirit of a
true
Floridian be knuckle
box yeah shirtless
fighting yeah are you uh
trying to be like more into
fighting not really but it's just like
like I I didn't give a [__] about that
in Florida but it's just there people
Everyone cares about it here now so I
mean you you you learn more about things
cuz now we're around the obsession of it
yeah so I hear more you know I don't
know why you it's what it's what every
sport is pretending to be what do you
mean by that they're like oh I can beat
you with this ball that means I can beat
you up
up you just beat each other up yeah
that's pretty funny I can see
that yeah I mean if there's a UFC
fighter and a football player yeah
you're going to be more afraid of the
UFC fighter I don't know I don't know
about that some same size same height
nah dude if if a football player like
[__] uh like like Ed if I see Ed Reed
or uh any any safety back there you
can't make it about size though what do
you mean you just run up size
immediately yeah no yeah UFC versus
football like football players can run
into you harder but M UFC fighters will
get you into a pretzel and make your
like butthole like you know they'll show
everyone your
butthole like football players that's
where your mind
goes what's the most like pull your dick
out oh my you know how to like
manipulate your body like a football
player that was
crazy that's that's what you're afraid
of oh
no oh my
God so that's what you're truly afraid
of huh so now now now we know why you
like that's what you watch nobody can
see my
butt my secret buts that's an important
thing you got take for granted that's
where my Bitcoin Cipher is it's my purse
my Bitcoin purse it's my
butthole I think it's I mean it's equal
it's how quick of a death you'd want
because each would be instant death yeah
any type of professional athlete a
professional ping pong player could kill
me I equivalence with the with a ping
pong paddle oh my yeah can you imagine
getting spanked by one of those
guys y that would be humiliation once
more that would be
crazy I what I never really got the
sexual humiliation thing of just like
getting stanked or like dick out people
like laughing you whatever wait you like
like you never got spanked as a not like
just the whole fetish of like Oh I
thought you meant as a kid we're talking
about spanking with the paddle and the
dick out and showing people but hole and
the that whole horn
category like that I don't think so I've
never done it though never been
humiliated yeah you know besides just
performance on oh wait you're saying you
are the one getting SP I thought you
were thinking about like spanking
someone else like
but it wasn't like humiliating I wasn't
like yeah look at show everyone your
[__]
ass terrible little ass you
[__] well what's the worst thing that
a dude could do to you then that's got
to be up there showing everybody your
tiny little dick dude I got I ice
plunged yesterday cold plunge
yesterday that went through my mind for
sure showing people my tiny little dick
post cold plunge cuz you have to do it
in the locker room you have to public
humiliation yourself it was brutal
yeah no one's
uh I don't know I don't think I've ever
thought of that in my
life well being a fear humiliated like
out of like getting beat up in public or
some man bested
you I mean but that's happened you lose
fight sometimes it's in public you know
but the worst thing yeah what's worse
than getting beat up in public just like
I mean hands fall down yeah the best
times was when the internet wasn't
around you know so it was like
elementary school and stuff so they if
if if it happened today that would be
horrible yeah you can't really do like
the well I I [__] him up too you can't
spread that lie anymore yeah every
somehow every Street Lamp has cameras
and [__] yeah they're just we're we're
all [__] the pen Opticon now we're
all just
Nars I don't
know I miss World Star I miss all those
videos this I don't Great era maybe I've
just falling off the algorithm but I
feel like they used to be more common is
it because people think they're no
they're being filmed or those just still
fully out there and I'm missing out well
it's still a thing it's not as big like
it
just uh they're they're way more you
know we we get we have everything on our
phones now so we don't need to go to a
website or it's it's the same thing but
they still have they cover news they
cover when you say we are we speaking
for the black community
or like as a we don't we just our phones
the whole the whole uh the whole Comm uh
yes cuz that's how World Star pretty
much got popping but I don't know it was
a big thing for a while but and now they
just cover like stupid
media it's just like TMZ yeah just D
pretty much stuff like that they like
you know but yeah it was always funny
going on there and it' be somebody
getting like knockout gamed and then
they'd be like and check out this new
rap video we're supporting like you're
just like
what what a weird combination of thanks
we're music promoters and you can watch
The Knockout
game no I've never actively looked at
those really never had a morbid
curiosity never never made a mistake on
Lime wire kazah and accidentally
downloaded something
horrible no the earliest that I remember
that was like middle school when they
were finding out uh I don't remember the
name of that group but when they were
just cutting people's heads off on
[Music]
YouTube that group yeah I don't I don't
was I was in Middle School in the
computer
lab fixing the damage from the cat oh
the cat [__] up
up oh there it is and we're back hey uh
check check is that a fire Festival
shirt like the fire Festival uh yeah I
got it on Amazon I was going to say you
you you paid for that Festival you were
going to go you went were you paid for
no oh
okay do you mind my girlfriend
joins I don't care okay um yeah I mean
uh this is a shirt I bought cuz I
watched the a thing on CNN I was
flipping through the channel in a hotel
and I saw this documentary about it yeah
and I was like oh my God if I have that
shirt now it'd be so
valuable and I look on Amazon and
they're selling this exact shirt yeah
and I don't know why it's in the Ukraine
colors it just how they've designed it
so
an authentic vintage Amazon purch shout
out to Billy you know he's out of jail
now he's out of jail and the guy that
did it yeah and he said he's planning
fire Festival
2 Dam so who's gonna fall for that
again I mean you're famous now you can
go this time you get sponsored there I'd
love to go thanks for reminding me about
that yeah all right what's your
association with festivals do you like
festivals it seems like you do well in
Festival
I I they're the worst I don't like
really big uncontrollable crowds I don't
really go to a lot of music festivals
and stuff like that I hate it but what
about all the shower and [__] and you
can have status [__] you can use your
status well when I get to that point I
feel like you're really good at
converting power into sexual favors
really yeah I I've been trying to get
better actually thank you for saying
thank
you use your natural skills like like a
hunter and the and the [__] you have
any notes on it for
him no I think it's great I mean it just
seems like um yeah but I don't have a
lot of power so the fact that you you
know not yet anyway so so that that's
what I'm working on next yeah that's
that's what uh keeps you from becoming
the next Michael Jackson or something
what power yeah just fiddling little
boys or something oh okay okay I like
you like you have to like like isn't it
funny like the most famous black child
molester first turned
white yeah so that's really on y'all
that's not something about turning white
makes you a child
molester he didn't want to he didn't
want to [__] up his side of the street
he's like I don't want this black people
I got to go
over yeah he's like I have a horrible
secret I got to turn white yeah he
walked out of his last like bleaching a
point held up like like to his skin like
one of those paint swatches he's like
finally finally I can
indulge that honestly might be the game
plan if if anything ever bad happens you
got to commit and turn white become a
whole different become a whole different
person but the same person have the
decency to turn white before he start
molesting be like Michael
Jackson respect the goat he did it for
the culture yeah
I think uh today's Michael
Jackson Drake would do
that uh you know I could see him turning
white at some point in his
career isn't he half white I think he's
Jewish is that the same thing as being
white I mean there's a long story
history of this question should how long
do you have no doesn't go watch to an
hour and I think he he's he's Jewish and
black but I maybe people be saying
that's black and white I don't know
Jewish dad or Jewish mom his dad's black
uh his dad's
black so then he's Jewish yeah you got
hit didn't his like dick pictures get
leaked and [__] and he has yeah that
[__] he is [__] I'm sure
everyone's making the same jokes but but
he's [__] everything that's [__]
unfair I didn't watch the video I'm I'm
uh I'm too straight for that but you
know I
don't I boycott that out of respect you
know it's but so you don't watch normal
porn just Dick's a normal porn no I just
edit it out yeah I use I blur it I
Japanese only just only trans for me
yeah only erotica I read you guys [__]
with AI porn yet you tried that [__] no
dude is that porn with humans or is it
two robots [__] I mean again long
story question it's no it's like
generative they like make
using yeah using the technology that
everyone has already that like to have
the guard rails on that one you can go
to like use copies of essentially that
don't have the guard rails and are just
made for like make generating naked
pictures and videos it's [__] scary
you can create the perfect porn yeah
whatever your mind desires yeah spot
baby that's kind of crazy just [__]
come every day like your AI just adapts
to you like your YouTube algorithm
and you're just every day just
like that it chat Bots built into it
already it's like you build your
girlfriend and then you can like talk to
it yeah no I can't I can't support that
[__] got to go outside go outside go
outside touch grass you Hoy nigg go be
poor somewhere and that'll be good for
you you get to the AI porn you're doing
too much man go socialize good the
better the porn gets the harder it is to
convince people to bomb a country that
they shouldn't be bombing it's like why
would I do that when I get so much
satisfaction from the porn I don't think
you have an unmotivated Workforce that
requires propaganda how many how many
bombies do you think we stopped because
of porn I don't think I don't think
that's the number one motivator of Love
of like I don't want to bomb this Middle
Eastern babe right there she's a thy I
like
no her live
a watcher from the skies there's
probably dude watching some Middle
Eastern our soldiers are out in the war
but they have pretty privileg
so all the AOS are dead in the Middle
East that's why they're all
hot oh my God M Le and girls are H yeah
just not the hairy ones it does seem the
countries that are at War do have like
the hottest girls ukrainians how would
you know like Saudi Arabia could have
the hottest girls we just just never see
them yeah that's that's why they hot
down they're like we're not going to
share this with you are you crazy I know
we're the Saudi Arabian fashion models
how how many are we missing out on Miss
Universe isn't crazy bro girls they're
living a whole other different [__]
world over there I just want to see Miss
North Korea and she's just some girl in
pigtails and all these other people are
supermodels and she just like like a
normal girl yeah just embarrassed for
her stupid female
body love seeing that I'm just
kidding out Kim Jung's
arum the hottest North
Korean I think they have to say that
legally well they'd have to come up with
a wild Vibe about winning it too
obviously because they couldn't take the
L so they'd have to come up with equally
insane lie to be like no we want dude we
actually won Universe we got the hottest
wands and they'd have to bring a bunch
of of like ugly versions of all the
other countries be like no see she is
the 10 actually because you've never
seen a 10 before we brought in a bunch
of fours to make a look look at this
white
Pig yeah everyone throw your celery at
her it's just like uh Chelsea Clinton
and see see she is Elena Dunham yeah no
this this is the American Miss Universe
Lena Dunham that's they're eating all
your food this could have fed seven
North
Koreans or one M of Denham do you have
your tour dates on your cover photo for
your phone I do not I have no tour
dates Thanks
Hans burn what is it you got like a
Bible verse no it's my it's my New
Year's resolutions for 202 you have like
17 New Year's resolutions I have 11 all
right there there's 11 of them I don't
even have one
uh you can make one right now it's not
too late yeah I resolve to ask you about
this what's your general theme of uh uh
number one is get funnier I mean there's
only 10 commandments yeah I I had to one
up it you know I had to go above and
beyond so what's the funniest thing you
could do right now
um what kind of question is that well
such a vague goal just be funnier uh get
fun yeah I it it is get Funny or Die
Trying just get funnier you know I don't
know I don't know I don't know how that
I you know I feel you just work and do
what we do but the more you
pursue the more you pursue it the harder
it is to be
it and then uh the last one number 11 is
meet madis and
Pettis is that a rounds out the list is
that a underaged person no know she used
the same age as me I don't know uh like
27 I'm 25 you thought I was 27 thanks
Hans I I tried to figure out how old you
were uh H got a call earlier and then it
I guess it was a Spam call and then they
go how old are you and I was like yes
I'm G to find a whole H and then he goes
I'm old enough to [__] your and then
hangs up the phone I was like damn I
want to I really want to know how old
this guy is well he's at least 18 now
you know he's at least 18 yeah that's
that's literally all I I know
I don't know much about I just know some
things that could be true yeah I don't
know well you could Google it probably
you think I could Google how old you
think it'll tell me the truth I don't
know I feel like it's weird Googling
your age I'm looking right at
you well it saves me a
step it be makes it different I don't
want to have the same conversation over
and over again so I Fair that's fair I
just make it about Google yeah but yeah
I don't know why that people think that
I'm a certain age and think certain
things about me and I'm interested to
find out what it is you exactly think
about me CU that's yeah important that
to manipulate how you think feeling well
I thought you were 29 that's what my
guess 29 yeah I'm going I'm going about
my age I'm going older how how old are
you you're pretty
young4 holy [__] you think I'm
34 I think you're 30 31 31 yeah oh my
God 31 well I'm sticking with my answer
27 no 29 yeah 30 to 31 to 34 to
29 what a bunch of numbers what a great
great age reveal then
reveal I don't know it must be is it
cool Googling yourself and you actually
pop up I like how me no I actually hate
yeah the fact that your name works like
that is cool I I don't think it's going
to be so hard for me to because my name
is Bobby Brown I have to like it's also
three other people popping up no matter
what
comedian it shows Tony Hench Cliff's age
when you Google my name but not yours or
his it says I'm
34 is it wrong it's
correct oh so you were right I'm known
for making a joke about Matthew Paris
after he
died that's number one oh wait that's
the one that made the New York Post uh I
was born on June 1st I thought I was
born on May
31st that's pretty sick that they get
your birthday WR you got it one day
wrong maybe that's my actual birthday
yeah you just don't know this about
yourself it your family was your family
was lying to you your whole life like
you were born at 1:00 a.m. but it's
close
enough and it was your mother's birthday
to too it's my mom's birthday so maybe
they fudged the the numbers a little bit
that's fine a lie my whole life so I
didn't have the same birthday you were
crowning and they're like close
off that's kind of sick my my uh they're
like pushing me out my girlfriend's
Chinese and she just doesn't know her
birthday CU she was a one child policy
adoption so she just has a random
arbitrary birthday wait what is what
does that mean they still have birthdays
well she just doesn't know it there's no
what did they do to those poor ch
they pull up like literally the adop the
parents rolled up in China for the
adoption like after all the paperwork
and money and they just like opened a
[__] truck like and then there's just
a bunch of Chinese children they're like
all right pick them up oh they were
Refuge are they were thrown away yes the
girls and so they were like here's a
bunch of babies that a Chinese person
working really hard America yeah kind of
a huge [__] come up better than rural
China whatever whatever yeah she kind of
danked out low key there's no way her
brother is doing better than her yeah
she she for sure got the best end being
free having free will in America you
don't think there's Chinese rich kids
going to universities and colleges in
America that's true that's true but the
girls in China are I don't know not
having a good time I heard oh yeah I
mean what do you think that is
propaganda
or I mean I wonder I always wonder what
it's actually like over there they're
they're poor than America for sure but
maybe it's more exciting to be on a
come- up team than like a fading Empire
yeah yeah honestly we should switch
sides we should
actually we should we should take a
little leap is it is so sad that it's
like how uh how everyone came to Austin
for comedy yeah and just left going to
China yeah I'm going to start comedy
club in
China get all your jok jokes approved
first she gets raided twice a
night like Lenny Bruce on like the 40s
you just like say something
someone that' be really funny when like
every comedian thinks they're oppressed
here and then to actually do it in China
and just instantly get black
bags Camp they get finally a hard days
of work in a
shower yeah they get David goggin just
forcibly against
their yeah that's the thing about being
in a oppressive country is like you know
you get a
workout you have to be on your toes like
yeah kind of makes sure like be in the
moment head on the swivel
yeah so do you think like America has
caused more harm to the world than good
or more good in the world than harm do
you mean our world the world that we're
living in which the Dimension yeah from
our perspective here in America I mean I
think the benefits of it are more
good yeah the benefits are good like
like from our side of the story I would
say for sure I'm not I'm not I I'm not
happy they did everything they did but I
I've had the opportunity to have a
really good life but maybe this is like
the norm
like it's nice that we have a nice life
but like what
did we deserve and what could we have
had that were prevented from that is
true but we're always gonna yeah this is
good enough yeah you mean I'm having a
great time you mean political system
wise or just like purely just material
money wage theft
yeah are you yeah because you're kind of
a interesting case because you you know
with living in the van before you had
that perspective and then now did that
change you politically at all like your
come up no I'm still a Comm
okay yeah you put it close to your mouth
sorry yeah sorry I think my headphones
are hot so oh okay let me turn you
down Jack Jack this see yeah up perfect
thank
you good yeah um yeah I mean I think
that uh we should take care of the poor
and being poor is not like a great thing
and yeah I think like that's all a
country should do is like keep people
from being poor like there should be a
bottom I condemn this yes as as someone
who has been broke for 24 out of my 25
years America is such a great country
but like the way that it treats its
people isn't like better than any other
country it's probably worse um I I know
very little about politics but I'm on
the side of every time I see that we
gave money somewhere that wasn't
directly to me I got pissed at this
country on the millions that every every
time they make a new a new announcement
um but yeah every time I see that I'm
like [__] send that to me to the
moood what the [__] yeah we should send
more money to the
hood Drake wees love the hood send that
directly to you know account yeah you
know how they gave money during the
pandemic what why don't we just start
doing that that would fix
everything do do you actually believe
that I can't
tell I think that would also help a lot
of things too
I'm pretty but do you think capitalism
is the best way to get enough money to
give everybody enough money or do you
think communism will get us there I
think that we need to
stop we just need to chill overall just
overall we need to chill yeah there's
nothing more to gain we're just
rearranging things yeah it's nice to
have a nicer iPhone but we should really
just chill out and discover what we're
going to be in the future after we get
to a sustainable place and then have
Star Trek and then space
space we should do space I really didn't
think that we would have been like just
casually going to space by now though
like how old are you 25 yeah oh my God
that dream was
dead long time ago really yeah space we
start going to the Moon in like the
70s I just it was I don't know dude it
was just a thing bro Back to the Future
and all that [__] what is there though
it's like we could go there and make
Mars like slight better than like the
Antarctica but it's like we we could
just stay here and chill out like it
takes so much work to get people up
there and we're you have to want to go
you know what I'm saying but I don't
know I can't wait till we can get
submarines up in there and we can just
have nuclear powerered
[__] things just floating over what's
the opposite sub like what was what
means
over sub
par uh what's the opposite of sub
Subzero there's no posit it's just
normal
yeah Surplus I don't know yeah I'm
anti-as travel pretty heavily though I
think it's stupid and boring I think
everyone I think people who think it's
like the great Frontier I think they
have lazy imaginations if they think
space is exci it's just a different Rock
like who gives a [__] you know mean
you're sitting on a different Rock doing
the same [__] I think this is the end of
the human race we can do robots robots
can go there for us and tell us what's
there and pretend you think we're the
last
Generations uh feels that way everything
is falling apart and the world is a
horrible place you are giving way more
reasons why we should leave everything
you just said is why I'm saying let's
get the [__] out of here let's go
actually build some [__] out there okay
let's go through the yall are on the
[__] it let it implode with us on its
side yeah let's go to the place with no
atmosphere that'll be that'll be easier
probably but in like a 100 years
somebody going to figure it out it's
going to be Little Einstein invent [__]
there
too no it was the Einstein was in rural
China so he never got he was a weager he
got genocided never never got to feel
his
cont I don't know I think space is
boring yeah we can do some other [__]
but that was just yeah it's like the
best we can make Mars is
like the goby desert but again you never
know you never know until you know like
some [__] might pop up next to us to
suppos to the bars tomorrow and that
might I think so I don't think that's
how space works you think it's like
Zillow it's better prices might come
along you don't know fresh some [__]
could pop up you know we know it's
aliens and [__] they could they could
move their house next to our house or
some [__] say hey we here come right
here I don't know do you I feel like
psychedelics are more of the frontier I
think the Psychedelic realm or that's a
lazy way to say it but I feel like the
next technology is going to be around
Consciousness not around going to a
different Rock but maybe I don't know
I'm mistaken I mean well I mean I I get
it you know I I know now that we're
never going to really get that far it's
not going to be open to the public not
in our Generations CU because [__]
couldn't even build a submarine that
worked to go somewhere properly
so we got to figure out the see
first come on
in I'm sure
to is this live or we pausing counting
I'm I think we're just going nice this
is how it
goes no no no I can't believe that first
of all you being 34 shocked me I thought
we were the same age I I just assume
that everyone who I meet is the same age
as me it's it's definitely depressing
being 34 in comedy it's uh starts to
feel weird it's the place where it's
starting to feel weird no that's closer
to the age where you know every
everyone's waking their best work bro
that's good true but it still is
ultimately uh telling dick jokes
strangers and stuff it starts to feel a
little peculiar if you're not having
wild success yeah because even moderate
success starts to feel odd you know like
what what do you mean by that it's still
it's a little uncanny sometimes just to
be like I don't know
you're talking about your can't to
strangers
hey he yeah what are you snacking on
I've met you like six times got me have
you really yes [__] Bobby Brown he's
offing at the
[Laughter]
sunset I don't think this thing's on not
often is it on I'm actually there
Saturday the Florida showcase you guys
should come I'll be there performing you
should come to my show the
black yes on Wednesdays on Wednesdays
meet
people what what nothing okay I can hear
you okay there's a uh headphones what's
your name hey I'm Nichol I he you Nichol
Nikolai
Nikolai did you say Nicole is this is
Hans doing that episode finally we're
gonna do one of those we're doing a
trans up Nikolai yes
Nicole is that your trans name yeah
that's what I was saying I was like are
you finally doing a trans episode front
yeah we should do a trans episode how
how do you do that
you just transition we could all be
girls so what do girls talk
about
um we could talk about dating and like
the way that people are like in the
day-to-day life like at restaurants and
bars any interesting experiences in
social life you could talk about periods
and cramps and childbirth oh you had a
couple of those your mic is really
loud
no it's a good
thing um it's just good you have a very
powerful female voice it's good that we
have a female voice balancing it out the
the
dudes but yeah we could talk about
periods and cramps
um but yeah any crazy things happen at
the open mics recently any anyone acting
weird
uh there there's like a dude who's weird
at Creek a lot he's just there name
names I don't know his name what's his
General demeanor uh he he just gets
drunk but he always sits on he he he
will sit for the whole mic like until
like until 2:33 in the morning he will
sit for the whole mic like an audience
yeah yeah he's not a comic but he's he's
a he he will cheer for everything after
a certain point I think that's that's
fun to know I just I just started going
there but it's always supportive cuz
when he's the only one in the
crowd it's like oh everything's killing
right now
thanks weird at the recently you mean
[__] everybody there what You' been
the Christian everyone's trying to be so
different and special and they're like I
don't talk in a normal way and when you
have everyone talking in a weird way
then it's like there's no common basis
of what do you mean talking in normality
like voice no like oh I I like to bring
up weird things let's do improv exercise
now and some people like everyone's
trying to be too [__] funny and weird
in conversation yeah yeah that is
strange when people try to force it way
too hard because they like listen to
come toown once or something yeah what
if a Jew was gay we weren't talking
about that at all that's kind of weird
that you brought that up yeah to riffy
or people that are just like giving you
nothing because they're like I save it
all for the stage this is an important
part of all right now yeah yeah you
about to do three minutes buddy
you're at Lucky Duck they don't even
turn off the TV for you oh god dude I
had to do a show where they were they
just played uh there was two TVs right
behind me and it was the playoffs I
thought they were going to shut it off
for the comedy show but it stayed on the
whole time like they had the game going
right behind me while I was doing my set
nobody was looking at me it was the most
awkward
[__] one TV I understand but there's one
on this side and then me or the stage is
and then the other one's right here they
were like all right guys can you get
that mic off that b they were like all
right guys now we're going to have a
comedian and everyone was just glued to
the TVs it was a playoff game yes it was
the just commentated it wor that would
have went better than that went for me
you think anyone's ever playing football
and then like a standup comedy open mic
pops up and then like oh my God
Everyone's Watching The Open Mic
nobody's watching us give our lives I
mean if Hans Kim walked in for sure
that's that would that's what would
happen if you just at the Super Bowl and
then
just it makes me suspicious if you're
gonna take it all away and insult me so
you can get your
way yeah I'm GNA America you that's my
plan America is a good country we just
are misguided on a couple country a
couple continents misguided on a couple
it's it's interesting that you're like
we're just slightly misguided you're
like oh how do you differ you're like
actually I believe in a completely
different political ideology in one
found I believe in communism oh yeah
we're we're mostly good well don't you
think America is so easily hijacked by
special interest groups and small
minorities of people because that's how
the system was
designed I do I'm definitely not like
some Pro like flag waver I just question
sometimes whether if communism would do
better necessarily at those things given
I don't think it's like less susceptible
to corruption or interest
groups yeah I mean I would just like to
see a more democratic version of what we
have
now true I'll take that letting people
actually vote would be cool yeah we
shouldn't be able to control the nuclear
power plants and decide what temperature
the reactor should be that
morning everyone just wakes up and votes
together like the fortune people get
together and they all what temperature
we want today guys Fukushima
temperature but I think we should be
able to maybe decide that maybe tax
return should be done by the government
and not by Turbo Tax into it an H&R
Block a thing that doesn't have to exist
and there's a whole [__] industry you
know it's just so inefficient at best
I've never gotten a good tax return i'
the most I've ever ever gotten was like
$134 I got $50 back this
year damn wow that's a that's kind of a
lot that's the government being like
here have a
dinner have one dinner on us yeah you
can eat for one night have shroom
gummies also can I comment on how
casually people just do shrooms now and
how much that's changed in the last like
two
years taking way less than like a Trippy
amount you know like you're not taking
like four gram and tripping balls they
just like chill having a beer yeah just
having a beer and a shroom I feel like
that's worse you're just giving yourself
the drug in smaller doses every day so
that you don't want to Fe I do feel like
it's harder for me to be happy now cuz
I'm like o you know I've just [__]
with my happiness for so long by taking
shms every day how long have you been
doing it every day for not every day
when or he gives them to me he's the
drug provider he's also the gun provider
he made me hold this guys I didn't want
I just noticed that that's scary
remember you were looking for the
formula earlier and how power guns and
drugs oh yeah those are the two
things yeah I mean I think uh weed and
mushrooms I mean mushrooms like just
because we consider them as harder than
weed doesn't mean they are like maybe
some cultures they do mushrooms before
weed and mushroom is just like not even
a significant thing to them I would say
it varies very much depending on the
dose you're taking you know what I mean
you can trip the [__] out on mushrooms
like you can't on weed yeah I don't know
yeah that's true I think sorry guys
sorry what I accidentally did incorrect
drug information cuz mushrooms are they
have a higher ceiling than weed yeah but
in small doses yeah I agree with that
for sure it does feel like less
sometimes especially then like a heavy I
I worked at a psychiatric emergency room
in Denver during legalization like when
when all the weed stuff was happening
and constantly just tourists coming in
who were just taking like entire
chocolate bars you know they would just
hit the [__] dispo they they get like
100 milligram edible and just some
mother from you know Atlanta would just
lose their [__] mind and have to come
into the emergency room to get calmed
down yeah that must have been
fun yeah just hearing people scream when
we handcuff them to a thing stop be on
chill you're only high you're just High
I have actual crazy people to deal with
[__] calm
down yeah that's what's gonna happen the
whole psychedelic real all that I I
can't fck with that yet I don't know
yeah it's not I think everyone should do
what they're comfortable with and what
you decide is what you're comfortable
with is probably what you should be
doing your brain has like a way of
telling you like hey trip out a little
bit like my when I was young when I was
18 I was like I need to do weed like
that was like important to me yeah
because I was just wasn't getting enough
happiness and the school slash study
life so I was like I need to be Counter
Culture I don't know I don't know why I
felt like that but what was what was the
stigma on weed when you were in school
was it like everyone was okay it or was
like a rebel thing I mean no one did it
I went to a Christian school but it was
like we all knew knew that all the
propaganda was false in high school in
Middle
School okay like it wasn't like a weird
thing what age were you when you were
like not into God I would have done it
like 17 or 16 but I did it in college
freshman year which I think is a good
age to wait cuz I think people that do
it too young can get [__] up but yeah
I my first time was I was
15 at
school and I used to not really [__]
with we at all but now I smoke pretty
much every day too much I used to think
it was bad and now it's just drinking I
mean some people take Lexapro every day
and it's not good for them but I think
some people need it because they're
dealing with a lot of uh trauma
maybe that's that character development
we were talking about earlier if they
didn't have it you think they'd still be
perfect I don't know I think I stopped
smoking weed for it's been like probably
two or three years like honestly the
only times I'm high now is in situations
like this where I'm just around comedian
in a small room it's so social like not
doing drugs makes you antisocial yeah
cuz then you can't go out for drinks and
people aren't comfortable with so I feel
like me not smoking cigarettes help
makes me miss out on a lot too cuz like
smoke people go smoke a cigarette
together somewhere and and I got as I
can't I'm like damn I don't I'm just
pretend just bring out like a fake
cigarette I just want to be around guys
I'll listen to the conversation if you
smoke drink smoke weed do mushrooms you
can join any social drugs I mean you're
not excluded cocaine cocaine is an
ultimate social one you you become
instant best friend it's like you can't
talk about it to other people without
sounding crazy like a secret it's in the
moment you sorry I interrupted you but
it was don't
that
it
no I was backing up with you were saying
I was saying uh Like Cocaine has that
like extra level of it where like you
have that thing of like just being a
joint rotation or something and you're
instantly friends just because like
you're breaking bread together
essentially yeah we're in this together
now yeah it's just that very human kind
of am Alan thing of like all right we're
sharing we're bibing is it Texas that
does it a lot because I feel like I've
done it a lot in Texas yeah I mean well
I I I've never been around it so much
back in Florida but here it's like
everyone does it so yeah that's so funny
they're like I buy American but then you
buy
cocaine like that's funding the worst
kind of people as close to us as
possible as bad for your local
environment for sure yeah support local
get mushrooms
yeah yeah I'm sure the [__]
legalization of weed really [__] up
the cocaine and Pablo Escobar [__]
yeah yeah I think it reduces like opiate
rates right like opiate overdosis where
there's like legalization
yeah so you're saying that once you
legalize drugs there's more overdo over
overdoses no I think if you legalize we
there's less opiate overdoses because
people use it that's smart I'm for
legalizing everything I know about you
guys but I'm down to everything you want
everything to be legal even
[Laughter]
guns what's the first thing to go I
would say guns are up there with like
Fen and
all being being illegal yeah well you
can't you can't put the toothpaste back
in the tube what was there like 300
mlion I mean they did it in Australia
true they start taking it away and guns
break down the only guns that are going
to be left are like antiques that tested
time
muskets people are going to be killing
each other using Old English
yeah bring back dueling when you you
know you just get hit with a gun and
even kill you
D like Lock Stock there are no more good
du anymore man dueling Jo today would be
hard yeah just full
clip 10 Paces Bro [__] You I'm had
enough of this [__] back to back drone
battle Xbox controllers oh [__] they
should bring drone battles is it like
Collision or is it like Miss missiles or
like guns I would say collisions just
try to blow run into them like a battle
bot in the sky type thing yeah aerial
Battle Bots put a gun on it why not I
mean you have both the components to try
this you can make this dream a reality a
drum gun there is a drone gun have you
seen the video I've shown you okay it's
a gun on a drone and it
goes and it like pushes the Drone back
oh [__] but I mean once you get that is
it accurate like
um is it accurate I don't know I just
Target it can be accurate all you have
to do is have a site on it and just oh
move it up oh move it up it just takes
trial and error that's [__] are
getting too
dangerous the Casual person is just
getting too dangerous
yeah um have you seen that little sci-fi
short film about drones that are like
that big and they land on your forehead
and and explode a tiny bullet that only
kills you in your little brain it blows
your brains out no what the [__] they
those and they can have a swarm of them
this is just a hypoth hypothesis it's
like a science short film but yeah I
mean they definitely do that what what
was the end of it it's like whoever
controls the Swarm controls and then it
just shows the last person living and it
shows like a [__] drone spotting it
it's like you're [__] [__] that's
horrible
but yeah I mean we have nukes already
it's like we could have killed ourselves
if that's what we really wanted to do
but hopefully the force is a good one
out it'd be cooler if the tiny drones
did like mind control instead of like
shooting through your brain like I feel
like there's better use of like creating
a swarm of drones to why do you got to
blow my head up yeah don't you want to
use my body or something like come on
that's green yeah a woman would suggest
mind control is the for
like that's way better than just
murdering them you can stalk them to see
if they're cheating on
you on
drone that's funny that that type of
drone stuff does make me wonder
sometimes why there's not more like
assassinations because you think it the
bar to do it it's getting lower and
lower we're just going to be investing
in armies and our drones are going to be
fighting above our heads and we're just
going to be talking to each other like
oh yeah we're at War right now our
drones
are that would be preferable
battle yeah why have battles at all if
it's like at that level and then we we
spend a lot of money on it that's like
interesting though like instead of like
losing people you just lose a bunch of
your [__] money it's like a big [__]
you to the government I bet that happens
like Russian and like American oligarchs
like Hey we're at
War
yeah those are
similar like wait are you sure were
again wasn't that 20 no it's back we're
doing it
again that is the money would probably
be more important than the people to
them like they just had to like spend
way more money on like automating
everything and people didn't have to do
it it'd probably stop having Wars yeah
it's too
expensive yeah if you can't push your
arms deals anymore doesn't really have
much of a
purpose yeah it used to be more
gentlemanly before Total War right like
at the turn of the century like Napoleon
era think so I think a little later than
that though like Civil War yeah like
Civil War and up to like I guess like
the 50 years after that like total war
was a concept that like evolved because
it used to not be that you just went ho
in all the way and like no matter what
to inflict maximum damage at any cost
there used we had alliances alliances
are really what killed
us it's working together that destroy us
yeah it have just been Serbia and
Croatia fighting and then it got
whatever it became but the
Germans they had to be
stopped yeah I would agree on that one
they were just going crazy but uh yeah I
mean uh Total War is crazy cuz now you
have like world wars and everything
explodes but back in the day you used to
be like
America fighting south southern states
or like France but France was like all
of Europe so I guess like there's still
like a lot of alliances back then too
but like Rome I mean they took over a
lot of
[__] I guess that's why they took over
because they had that like Rich history
of all forming alliances and playing
that like war game and so like when they
the rest of the world got globalized
they're like well we've been we've been
right on top of each other for [__]
ever so we're ready for this [__] yeah
and everybody else wasn't used to that
type of maneuvering yeah well I don't
know I you think you're prepared for a
raid if someone just tried to raid Texas
right now and take us over
oh my God Texas would be a pain in the
ass to take it's a pain in the ass to
driveth
through to get anywhere you just have to
control so much area yeah you can get in
here through the southern border but you
can take over 35 but taking over 183
would be a pain in
ass that's the people's Highway yeah
that's what everybody here dreams of
happening or an adversary occupying them
like World War I Poland just mean if the
homeless people baned together they
could probably rise up yo they could
probably take over Texas yeah we're just
going to send our homeless people out
first test the
waters Cannon poter yeah dude the amount
of [__] here yeah this probably the
hardest place to take
over you have this yeah this small
arms uh and and all the illegal [__]
there's more illegal [__] here than any
other any other state I bet really I
just haven't seen it yet tanks illegal
tanks oh [__] where do you think which
state do you think has the most illegal
tanks Florida or Wyoming I would say
Texas is up there for sure Florida and
Texas got to be neck and neck there's so
much space here you could hide a tank I
haven't even thought about that now I'm
just going to dve past houses to be like
it's probably T you a flamethrower
there's more flamethrowers here probably
I've never seen one of those that wasn't
on the internet that would be cool as
[__] though if I'm on if we're on Sixth
Street doing show and then outside of
just the dude with a flamethrower walks
by that would be badass it should be
legal you can carry a gun why can't
carry a flamethrower cuz I didn't think
people think about stuff like that who
who would just want wake up and get a
flamethrower
Texans who would walk around with it
that's dangerous open carry flameflower
that's got to be a Google
search what's the limit of open carry
how far does it go how is kerosene can
you
have it sounds like a Carlin bit
honestly those uh those [__] horse
cops would be
[__] if the just brought a
flamethrower to six Street yeah what are
you going to do with your [__] horse
one come on now just bring back World
War II hero battles Cal we charges into
flamethrowers that would have been so
dumb that's perfect they could they
could just blow up your car CU you're
not in them so now y'all can't get back
to the
cars if there was like three people with
flamethrowers on six street at the same
time you know that that would be rap
going for the high score on mass
shooting with a
flamethrower just locking everybody into
those three blocks on six Street I would
apologize I'd be like yo we sorry man
whoever you know how hard it is to burn
brush imagine trying to burn human
beings just over and over again think it
takes a while yeah it's like barbecuing
Pig with a flamethrower yeah you're not
going to get it all cooked in one one
squirt just hit one of those pedal cars
on the way by dude just [__] everyone
just have to jump into that dirty ass
River at the end of the
corner stop drop and roll yeah everyone
stop drop and rolling that would be the
most disgusting stop drop and roll that
street is dirty as
[__] dir with sin that [__] place
stop dropping get
AIDS just open needles and gum on the
ground [__] I like how you put gum in
that last
year have AIDS plus e
duck into the gum so it sticks up like a
[__] bungee pit of AIDS yeah yeah the
[__] the vietamese
traps AIDS
traps San Francisco would be hard to
take over without getting AIDS yeah they
have the they got all the Berserkers
there the homeless Berserkers with all
their
drugs ready to
go our front
lines what what would be the who who do
you think would get taken over first in
the country first last probably like uh
I don't
know like
Connecticut they got some [__] out there
they got they got a lot of rich people
yeah they probably got some people
that's those people would surrender
first like I don't want you to bomb my
home here take it over I'll salute H why
are they
Australian they're Blue
Bloods and the trans Atlantic accent
yeah it's funny yeah they're like
Switzerland they just become a neutral
territory immediately yeah that's what I
guess that's what Switzerland is there's
a bunch of rich people that are like we
don't have to do this that's what the
uncivilized British countries are
for that was a good move honestly I'd
prefer that over the occupying other
countries IDE well they still benefit
from they like do the banking of all the
evil [__] really yeah that's how they
make their money they were in control of
that they're like the iron banking Game
of Thrones yeah they're like a step
above the Cayman
Islands the chocolateers those
[__] haven't you SE Wolf of
Wall Street he goes to Switzerland no
I've never seen it before who's
that you this guy brought up a [__]
Percy Jackson reference and he doesn't
know Leonardo DiCaprio's oh no no dude
that's cuz he's [__] 10 years old he
doesn't know [__] [__] yeah what kind
any
references Martin scors no but I do know
Percy
Jackson is it old is is it no it came
out in like 2016 and it's a thing
everyone knows just not me just like a
really popular movie there's probably
people on in your YouTube comments who
who agree with me they people haven't
heard of this so I think everyone's seen
it
yeah the Barbie girl yeah what's her
name from Australia
Margo yeah she's Leonardo DiCaprio's
wife I think yes it's a giant movie all
right I'll check it out you gotta watch
it acting like it's some indie don't
worry I'll leave IMD review I got you
I'm yeah support my short film The Wolf
of Wall Street starting Leonardo
DiCaprio Dam should we bring qus back
those look like a [__] good time
done qus no they do they do look fun
though I don't know why it turned to you
the person with a lot of they like the
ultimate like sedative have you done
them no so it's like Xanax oh it's a
pill yeah sounds sounds like a liquid it
sounds like thumbs
yeah
qu a liquid
for yeah it turns out thought it was
just
like katum and they were all tripping
out no I heard qu was crazy but it's
like I think it's like a Opia I think
like fentanyl Does It
Better Does It Better
yeah if you got the right dosage fenel
is great gets done with the whole thing
real
quick put a nice little bow on it yeah
let's get rid of the we got to go like
when you get caught with fentol you're
like [__] do the whole
thing that's how isn't that how I'm
isn't that how juice World whatever he
he was about to go on a plane or
something just took all the pills cuz
someone like snitched on him or whatever
I don't know but that would be a
horrible way to die you can't just do
all the drugs at that time yeah fentanyl
is not a good drug to carry around with
you you're not goingon to you're not
going to go to jail but you're going to
die on the drive home in the car you
want to just carry enough fentol for a
quick snort
everyone's carrying around a thimble
full of fent
andol yeah just do a little bit if
you're going to do it hot I love you I
don't want you to do it at all but just
do a little bit if you yeah if you're
doing coke in this city you're going to
do a little bit of fob
accidents Little Hair of the Dog little
flavor just a date pinch of fentol yeah
like when they describe things on the
back of like food packages just a hint
of a whiff a light dusting a coting of
opioids meth's a good one because you
it's pretty [__] hard to overdose on
so you could slam it all before how do
you know this I did used to work in the
psychiatric Emergen Jesus Christ yeah a
lot of so yall were like giving people
you know the doses that people could
take before like without dying well meth
you can just kind of keep doing you're
not really gonna you know die you can
die from withdrawing from alcohol but
you can't die from like math or anything
really Without Really Trying to it's one
of the Aderall is totally safe 100% yes
it's probably not good for your
brain it's amazing for your brain it's
like your brain's like working out all
day it's like pumping the
weights really yeah that's out all huh
huh like brain steroids but well you
love meth
then if you love
Aderall Amazon recommended I don't know
the Aderall is kind of a lot I'm like I
can't even imagine something way
stronger sounds like it would be
stressful you probably think you have
control of the [__]
world I feel like a genius that's what I
have heard from people because first of
all to your point of like doing it all
before you go in there was never any
extra math like there you never found
any MTH from people but to the other
point that's their first reaction yeah
because they're
like but there's like you you talk to
people whose life is in absolute
shambles on meth and they're like I'm in
control I'm doing it right like they
never are like oh [__] it's falling
apart like you just do math and you're
like I want this to happen I like this
overpass this is where I want to be this
kind of you know they're all aligned
they're like even though I don't have
much it's what I want to do and that's
something we could all learn from
method you just gives you super good
gratitude
yeah sounds like a great office
worker yeah somebody who'd be slotted
into an office was perfect yeah yeah we
should fill up the Google sale
buildings lease this is a untapped
resource if this was Seattle it would do
that they would they would uh drop up to
a hamster wheel they should generate
electricity through the homeless and
turn intoit coin have them all on bikes
on downtown yeah why are we not tapping
into this pay them 25 cents an
hour you can beg while you do it
that would be a crazy source of that
like imagine if there and you can just
have like a power set you can charge
your phone here thanks to the
homeless you giving them phone charer
Powers is crazy you need to build these
like the city bikes in New York but just
have them stationary hooks up to like a
a
tower someone pulls up with their Tesla
and they're come on run run come on
faster yeah your Wi-Fi goes out you go
outside to see what's wrong hey man you
know
hard he's just
likeing off it's like a hamster wheel
but the drip is
fenal they're chasing it that would be
crazy I I can't I don't know if that was
an option would you like like if if it
buy homeless yeah if if if the city came
to you and said hey man we can either
keep giving you guys power or y'all can
have these four people right here yeah
$80 a month for electricity or you pay a
onetime fee or a th you get the whole
homeless person
no long-term investment it's 25 cents an
hour it would take so much longer to to
amount to that I've been wanting to
invest in 2024 I'm gonna buy
10 yeah I mean obviously we should get
them homes and education and turn them
into
functional uh members of
society and we can you capitalize on
their
uh their energy later but right now they
just need help to turn into something
useful
later a no go ahead no I was gon to say
I agree yeah I mean seems
straightforward
yeah there's a place in Austin that like
does they have like a bunch of little
tiny homes and they like will invite you
if you're homeless to stay there and you
like work for the community but they
charge like $1,000 a month so it's like
kind of a
sham they charge more than the people
get paid yeah that's like how much I pay
in rent I feel like you go into debt
like living in this community but was to
help it's like the factory system in
Detroit where you like worked for the
company and lived in the company thing
and shopped at The Company Store just
doing all that's jobs let me just pay
you enough for you to just you know keep
coming back keep having to work here
we're not going to pay you too much
though so uh what about
uh
unions what is that
it's where people come together in a
company and say you got to pay us all 20
bucks an hour or else we're going to all
quit together and your company oh the
stickup yeah okay I would love I would
love to be a part of that one day I've
always wanted to be a part of a coup
like but that's not it's not a coup it's
like how the system should function is
with the thread of Labor walkouts
because otherwise it's just all
capitalists trying to maximize profits
yeah so you need the push back or else
they're just going to take
everything so you think that's the best
method you think that works Union yeah
the threat of Labor walkouts and they
can threaten you know withholding pay
and making you pennyless poor I that got
like the pilots and all that [__] when
they do when they were all threatened to
stop working oh the traffic controllers
yeah so if your job's important enough
it'll work but yeah but they failed yeah
yeah the Reagan uh the traffic
controller threatened and then he fired
them all and he hired new ones I was
like whatever we don't need
you I I was talking about like the
pilots recently the yeah recently when
when they were saying stop working yeah
like you know everyone bands together
it's time to you know Stick it to the
Man us the bad guy there should be more
of that yeah who should we who should we
stick up first the healthc care
companies and the finance companies they
are a parasite upon our
society and whoever taxes is we should
get them [__]
too yeah that's us it goes back to
us whoever it is that is leveraging
these taxes on us we should go for them
we should take our roads to get there
what we should do should just be the
price I think uh you want to call it a
podcast you want to end it or you want
to keep going
I'm good whatever you I'm officially
accidentally High which is nice thanks
for the freebie one extra riff what do
you think about uh the
immigrants cross I think some of them
are fine we should let those ones
stay based on what criteria race gender
go ahead hey you know so you just want
to up
the the beauty of America yeah we we
need to what about a lot of what about
the muscles what about the strong and
the capable and intellectually creative
like hey if you're good at the Rubik's
Cube we want you here that's what you
consider strong I mean what do you think
like okay all the Rubik's Cube rub Cube
guys are intellectually strong they can
contribute to our
economy or maybe like hey if you you
know like fortnite or Minecraft you have
extra m craft abilities or you're good
at you know drone simulation simulators
you could fight in our army we should be
picking like the the most uh useful
Mexicans and hiring them here we pay
them in v-bucks or whatever instead
yeah I'm kind of the opposite take I
think we should take the worst of them
so they take the worst of our jobs and
not our good
jobs yeah we only let in the absolute
worst do any so we can feel better about
ourselves yeah exactly like instead of
these super Mexicans just making us look
ugly and dumb yeah you ever work with a
Mexican before dude they do laps around
you nightmare I don't want that [__] I
already got to compete with robots now I
got to compete with immigrants that's
two hardworking groups to me man only
[__] Mexicans and then you be like
oh I did as much work as a Mexican
today okay should we end it
sure sounds like it guys thanks Hans
thank you for having me high as [__]
Almo Draft House every